الكثير من النجوم يتحدثون من يتحولون من
الفقر الى الثراء لكن اولئك الذين نشاوا
في اماكن فقيره يواجهنا اكبر العقبات
والعنف والجريمه خاصه تلك المنتشره في
احياء امريكا الجنوبيه ووسط امريكا القاره
التي تضم ثلثي اخطر مدن العالم الاكوادور
مثال بالطبع الحكومه خرجت من بعض الاحياء
وتركت المدنيين ضد المسلحين وعصابات
المخدرات وهنا يظهر مهاجم منتخب بها في
المونديال انر فالنسيا وعد بالتبرع باي
اموال يحصل عليها لمساعده الاطفال على
الانتقال من المناطق الاكثر خطوره قد ينجح
لاعب واحد في خفض معدلات الجريمه كما يحدث
في المكسيك انخفاضه معدلات الجريمه في
اوقات مشاركه اللاعب خيار مع ناديه حينها
من مانشستر يونايتد
[موسيقى]